parce que tu penses que j'aurai des gros
nichons en jouant ainsi j'en suis à un
point où tu peux mettre le couvert en
attendant tu peux pas frapper [ __ ]
blaireaux en même temps c'est un peu ma
chambre s'attend de lui prêter sa
chambre bah oui ça m'ennuie pourquoi te
demande pas sa marque serait rectangle a
besoin 10 passes pour écrire pour écrire
ressembler un couple au bord du divorce
ont vraiment mis cet album appelé papa
aussi
c'est ce qu'affirme tu gères l'éducation
ton fils je m'occupe de cette machine ok
ça c'est vrai je peux t'aider là il ya
quand même trois millions d'animaux qui
sont bloqués dans des hangars et je ne
vous dis pas le stress qu'ils ont c'est
juste une énorme tempête en fait
taymor on enterrait prénom partir en
vacances oui non en fait ses funérailles
la femme de mon père le père ma femme
fait longtemps qu'il m'a pas regardée
comme ça je trouve qu on est en voyage
on visite un lieu qu'on ne connaît pas
prendre à m
oui on découvre une culture différente
de celle monde 1
mais ça fait partie de l'expérience des
leçons de vie du père castor
mais c'est très agressive sur sa joue
beaucoup sur l'attitude de l'ue 6 4
c'est une non bien sûr j'étais femme à
merck la occupe toi de ton père de
vosnon biais de bourran coeur et puis tu
me laisses tranquille
pour nous avons un écran père haut
niveau
breton grand père nous a pas vraiment
avant de nous taire devant nous et toi
tu fais aucun effort
tu as l'air triste
trop vite me faire du saut en longueur
et papa cause de cette rancune à
l'avenir de la merde qu'on est tous
réunis
la preuve est qu'on se retrouve un peu
en juin
c'est un beau joe pardonne et il
mais